and up next Wilson J's new track
shooting up the charts us and the son
[Music]
[Music]
this song is a Bop
who did this to you were they out of
their minds don't worry we're gonna
figure this out sometimes the answer
ain't obvious you're gonna have to look
hard
okay maybe even crack a code or two to
solve this mystery if something seems
out of place or particularly interesting
take a closer look with some good
old-fashioned sleuthing I'm sure we're
gonna be able to figure this out oh I
loved your band by the way Avery P oh I
know was there another guy you're
kicking me off the texts okay firstly it
was a Facebook message and second it's
just not working out Fred hurry this is
unbelievable well I haven't been late in
weeks practice started it - what about
the record deal exactly we have this
awesome opportunity we have to be
serious
you guys are the ones who are just
whatever
you know I've always kind of fancied
myself as a performer
sometimes I even like to do a little
show for the bodies that was a joke
didn't come out right
Oh a tan line on her finger we should
investigate that further and forget
about other things
[Music]
Wilson yeah sorry oh well woman's I
wanted to show you my new song oh I'm
all yours babe shows that's out tonight
oh my superstar here we go it's almost
time for us to be carried away but
can I go
Oh
[Music]
I said
[Music]
stop it I just wanted to save the moment
[Music]
huh what something's different
I don't know what you're talking about
maybe it's the accurate scent of murder
just floating through the room yeah I
smell it too
smells bad baby
[Music]
and I cry
[Music]
[Applause]
you worry about your thing find your
little clues to your murder mystery I'm
gonna do me
thanks doll get up I finally got you an
interview
yay what if though I didn't that's also
an option okay I know you're sad about
what's face name I don't have to the
radio says it every hour on the hour
maybe you can learn a thing or two from
him
I'm gonna quit find a new career
something easy be ready at 4:00 Siri
ordered pizza art is to the artist as
breath is to life without your art Terry
you couldn't breathe I don't know it's
just a guess I mean I guess it's
executive hein is what do you think
was it Fred the ex-bandmate
Wilson Perry's Rockstar boyfriend or was
it Julie
Perry's manager I hope you've been
paying close attention throughout the
story did you notice anything odd well
let's start with a sticker seems suspect
to me it just kind of looks like
nonsense I wonder what happens when we
move the letters around
[Music]
a letter hmm what's the ninth letter of
the alphabet
what could this be applied to a series
of numbers perhaps and once again Wilson
J with us and the Sun last night was
wild its but this is our life now oh hey
hold on I got another call hey yeah hey
you little [ __ ]
you stole my song I got no idea what
you're talking about
we're done okay are you fine
I'm sure the tip line at amplified news
would love to hear about this
[Music]
[Music]
rockin the hole forever Perry
[Music]
and
[Music]